>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington DC.
>> Anne McLean, Music
Division, Library of Congress:
I am Anne McLean from the
Library's concert office
and it's my great pleasure
tonight to be talking
with all four members
of the Artemis Quartet.
We're expecting three
out of four
and we've got the whole quartet.
This is very exciting.
Gregor Sigl, Anthea Kreston,
Vineta Sareika, and
Eckart Runge.
Welcome.
>> [Unison] Thank you.
>> Anne McLean, Music
Division, Library of Congress:
Probably some of you
know this quartet is one
of the most foremost
groups on the stage today.
Their superb artistry,
stellar musicianship,
and sheer exuberance make
their performances memorable.
The Financial Times talks
about a vitality that's
utterly compelling.
And probably a few of
you tonight, like me,
have a wonderful memory
of their appearance
with us a few seasons back.
Eckart, you've performed
here then.
But you're the only
one of this group.
But Anethea, you performed
at the Amelia Quartet
-- Trio, didn't you?
>> Anthea Kreston: Yes I did.
>> Anne McLean, Music Division,
Library of Congress: Wonderful.
So we -- that's one
of the things I thought
would be interesting to talk
about is continuity and how
groups change and develop
over time and new people
and so forth and so on.
You appear regularly
in an impressive number
of the world's great concert
halls on four continents.
And I believe you now
curate your own series
at three of them.
Say which ones they are
and how you work these.
How do you do it?
How do you fit that in?
Gregor.
>> Gregor Sigl: we do a series
in our hometown in Berlin
as well as Vienna and in Munich.
And that's we -- go there
three times a season.
We do three programs
each season.
And it's very demanding, but
it's actually quite a feeling
to -- we realized that the
audience becomes friends
with us.
And if you go there regularly,
you have a totally
different atmosphere
when you enter the hall,
and you get a reception
that is very different
from just visiting once
or twice each couple of years.
>> Anne McLean, Music
Division, Library of Congress:
Do you have -- do you choose
your own repertoire for each one
and a do you ever do
educational commitments
or outreach or anything?
No time, really, probably.
>> Anthea Kreston: Well,
we are all four professors
at the University of
the Arts in Berlin,
so we have a full load there.
I think we take care of around
40 or 50 groups there as well
as some master groups that
come in just to work with us
in short-term periods.
And we are also master
teachers in Brussels,
the Queen Elizabeth Chapel,
and there we have six master
groups to do the same thing.
They live in different counties
and they come for several days
and work individually with us.
So we are kind of maxed out
with the old education stuff.
But which is important
and a great part
of our lives, of course.
>> Anne McLean, Music Division,
Library of Congress: Oh, my God.
I am sort of amazed because I
know your touring schedule is
hefty and to be able
to add that...
>> Vineta Sareika: We are
not teaching this week.
>> Anne McLean, Music Division,
Library of Congress: Yeah.
You have -- this is a
multi-city stop tour
in the U.S. How many cities are
you going to be in now here?
>> Vineta Sareika: We
are doing 11 concerts.
>> Anne McLean, Music
Division, Library of Congress:
That is a lot, more than
your last tour, I think.
Yeah.
>> Vineta Sareika: So we started
the tour yesterday in Princeton.
It was very nice.
>> Anne McLean, Music Division,
Library of Congress: Uh-huh.
That's a nice, nice venue.
>> Vineta Sareika: Yeah.
>> Eckart Runge: We
are still quite fresh.
[ Laughing ]
>> Anne McLean, Music Division,
Library of Congress: Yeah.
I can understand.
>> Vineta Sareika: So next
week we are going to Ann Arbor.
>> Anthea Kreston: And that
was Kalamazoo, Ann Arbor...
>> Vineta Sareika: Houston,
New York, and the West Coast.
Three concerts on
the West Coast.
>> Anne McLean, Music Division,
Library of Congress:
Well, we are lucky.
We'd tied for you last time
and we couldn't capture you.
So this time, we're lucky.
I know that Beethoven has
remained a focus for you
since the quartet was founded.
And that one of your early
formative experiences was a
shared passion to
master the Grosse Fuge.
So I want to ask about that how
you engage with Beethoven now.
I know you have a residency
and an honorary membership
at the Beethoven House in Bonn
which is pretty interesting.
You can see a really
masterly performance
by a very young Artemis quartet
in a documentary
called Strings Attached.
And if you happen to have a
Medici subscription you can find
it on there.
And it's kind of fascinating.
It's one of the cleanest
and most precise
that I've ever heard actually.
And this is when you
were much younger.
So are you still engaged with
this work and does it...?
Yeah, how is a figure
in your lives?
>> Eckart Runge: I think
Beethoven has been a very
essential part of our repertoire
throughout the whole history
of the quartet and I'm sure
and I hope that our readings
and interpretations
of Beethoven's music have
changed throughout the years.
But somehow we always felt
so connected to this music
and we had two wonderful seasons
where we played only Beethoven.
We did the whole
cycle for two years.
And the most remarkable
experience for me
in this time was I
was little worried
that playing Beethoven two years
would be maybe a little too much
and we would start to miss
Bartok and Shostakovich and --
but the truth was that
we couldn't get enough.
It was like addictive.
Because the music has everything
a whole concert program needs.
And it has the connection
to the tradition
and also the huge modernism.
So I think probably
this was the fact
that we felt most connected
to, that Beethoven was
so modern for his time.
Probably the most modern
of any composer ever.
And on the other
kind, of course,
connected to the great
quartet tradition.
And we somehow always
strongly identified with that
and it's just a pleasure to see
how this music developed also
through the different formations
of the group and just because of
who we played last season.
We did it a lot.
And so this work has
always accompanied us.
>> Anne McLean, Music Division,
Library of Congress: You know,
I was -- I ran across
a note somewhere
that you can see online the --
Beethoven's own transcription
of the work for four
hands and I wondered
if you'd ever played it.
I will send you it if you
would like, but it's kind
of fascinating to see this
on -- in a manuscript score.
But the reason it stuck in my
mind is that, as you'll read
in the program notes tonight,
Schumann, Clara Schumann played
through Haydn, Mozart, and
Beethoven quartets to learn them
and to understand the format
before he began to write his.
And somehow when I read about
this, it popped into my mind
about this Beethoven
[inaudible].
>> Gregor Sigl: Yeah.
It has been -- we
actually did a program
when a piano dual played
the Grosse Fuge, four hands,
and after the break -- or
other way around, we played it
in the string quartet
version and it was incredible
to see how different it is.
It's an entirely
different thing --
>> Anne McLean, Music
Division, Library of Congress:
So instructive, you know,
to see how he's thinking
[inaudible] and ideas and so on.
By the way, I always
have to tell people this
that this is the --
this portrait behind us is
the real Heckel portrait.
It's an original.
Beethoven House has another one,
but we are proud
to have this one.
>> Gregor Sigl: We
will tell them.
>> Anne McLean, Music Division,
Library of Congress: Would you?
Great. Okay.
So Beethoven continues
certainly to be a focus for you.
And it is a hugely
important element
in your identity,
really, as a quartet.
And this question of identity
was one that was on my mind
when I knew you were coming.
Thinking about your quartet
and other significant ones
like Takacs, Julliard,
Alban Berg, and many others,
quartets have been -- that
have been in existence
for decades growing
and developing
as quartet players
come into the new ones.
And I saw an article in the
Strad magazine that touches
on this about how quartets come
to create their own
identities and voices.
This -- there's a
man name Tully Potter
who writes a lot about quartets.
He's an historian of quartets.
And I think it was his
concept of the fifth partner,
an indefinable presence
that defines a quartet.
It sounds very eerie, but
it was so interesting.
And I wondered what --
how do you feel that
things get passed along?
How does a group evolve
when you change colleagues?
What do you concentrate on?
And what are the
challenges in recalibrating?
>> Gregor Sigl: I mean
what is fascinating is
that simply the amount of time
you spent together working
on music is so intense,
it's different
than anything else you do
rehearsing without musicians.
It's even way more
intense than studying.
You don't have a teacher that
is right next to you for 5,
6 hours a day and inspires
you or tells you what is wrong
or you can tell what is wrong.
So the influence we have on
each other is very strong.
And think that is also the
answer why there is an identity
of a quartet.
It comes a product of many
influences and it becomes yours.
We influence each other and we
find something that is common.
And that -- it's also passed on.
If someone leaves --
it is our experience
that if someone leaves,
it's not necessarily a loss.
You should keep that, what the
person brought to the quartet
and add something new.
It can be the opposite.
It can be a huge
development too.
So that's what we are trying
to do keep all these treasures
with each new member coming to
the quartet, add something new,
add a new color, new power,
fresh blood that's
something very healthy to do.
>> Vineta Sareika: You know it
is such an incredible feeling
when you come to a
group that has existed
since 15 years in
my case -- yeah.
Yeah, it's like the feeling
to sit down in a limousine
that is already on its way.
Everything is working and you --
there are so many interesting
things and those little details
that you speak about in the
rehearsal that you can just take
of it every day, and...
So I think the most important
thing for new member is
to be open-minded and to, yeah,
to really be very attentive
to everything that has
been done in the group
and on the other hand,
the remaining members should be
open-minded for the new impulses
that are coming from new person.
>> Anne McLean, Music Division,
Library of Congress: Well,
what I heard in the rehearsal,
you just sound superb.
You'll be just astounded.
Their sound is gorgeous
and huge.
But I can imagine that -- I know
something about the backgrounds
of each of you and your
work as chamber musicians
and this is an amazing
amalgamation of talent and ideas
and it's interesting that
your sound is so blended and
yet individual to what I hear.
And I know something
about your solo work
with orchestras and so on.
And you have had a very --
you started with a quartet
and then also a trio and you've
had major chamber experience
with so many great players.
And I know something about
your tango playing and your --
but many other things.
And Gregor is both a
violinist and violist
and so it's really a
remarkable group in this way.
We wanted to talk with
you a little too about:
how do you rehearse?
I heard you talk maybe on an
interview about how you rehearse
as if you are performing almost.
That you are so intent and
I loved that description.
I hadn't heard people talk
about it like that before.
You think of rehearsals
as repetitive, you know
>> Eckart Runge:
Well, I think --
well, we try to focus on is
that we don't do the
music for ourselves.
It doesn't make sense
that we enjoy the music.
I mean, we do.
But that's not our issue.
The issue is to pass over
the emotions to the public.
So I think this is -- and the
public's not right next to us.
So sometimes we have to
play a little differently
than we hear it on our place
because it has to sound right
in the 15th row of a concert
hall and not on our lap.
So I think to do that or to be
in that mode or in that spirit,
every rehearsal has to have
the focus on how do we get
out what we think the
composer intended emotionally.
And it doesn't make sense
to rehearse at 30 percent
because then you
practice wrong things.
And so it might be a little
tiring to rehearse as we do,
but I think it is the only way
to achieve this goal to bring
out the emotional goosebumps
or whatever you want
to call it out in the hall.
And, yeah, that is just
a thing we've always done
from the very first day somehow.
I don't know why, but we did.
>> Vineta Sareika: I think also
technically it changes a lot
if you don't rehearse
100 percent.
With the adrenaline
of the concert
and the stress will
be huge if you are
in a different situation,
if you've never felt
that before rehearsing.
So that's another reason
why we try to keep...
>> Anne McLean, Music
Division, Library of Congress:
And I think you were
saying one --
in this interview that I
watched that you always feel
that if you do something
a little differently
that quartet colleagues
will be very supportive
and they will notice you.
And, you know, you don't --
it's like have a
network underneath you
or a net underneath you.
You never have to think about
it [inaudible] the freedom
to experiment and
jump out there.
I was thinking when you were
talking about the expression
of emotion, I was thinking
when had the Minguet Quartet
here a few months ago,
we had an interesting
conversation with them
because they were playing the
Zreutzer Sonata of Janacek
which is, of course,
that's a very intense
and dramatic program
based on the told story --
short story and it has many
tremendous psychological shifts.
And if you've ever
seen a picture --
you remember the
old Taboo perfume ad
where the man has a
violin in one hand
and he grabs a woman
with the other?
That image is sort
of relates to this --
some people relate
that image to this.
But anyway, what was interesting
was that they said --
we were talking about
programs and whether they chose
to pursue a programmatic
approach or abstract approach.
They said vigorously
that they do not look
at any exterior sources.
They do not think about
the program at all.
They only go for the abstract
music and they work from that
to create their own
version, their own drama.
And I was just curious
about that for you.
>> Anthea Kreston: Do you
mean when we are programming?
When we're figuring out which
pieces should go to together?
>> Anne McLean, Music Division,
Library of Congress: No,
I mean literally do you
or do you choose to read
such background material
and learn
about the history and so on.
>> Anthea Kreston:
Oh, I absolutely do.
We probably are all
different actually
and that's quite different.
And that's probably very good.
But I'm a big, big reader
and a big researcher.
And I try to -- whether
it's even something related
to that particular work.
I'm constantly drawing
things from around
that period maybe historically
what was happening at the time.
What wars were happening.
What was happening with
that's person's life.
What was happening with her
love life, with their children,
everything absolutely.
It's all -- and when I hear --
when I hear -- I'm always --
I want more [singing] cu-la,
I'm always -- I'm always --
and they're like, okay, it's a
little too much [singing] cu-la.
Or I'm like [singing] cula.
And so I'm always -- I'm just
thinking about, you know,
Robert and Clara and then Brahms
and then I just, you know,
I'm always put too
much cula on there.
But, I mean -- that's
because I -- yeah.
And everyone's different and
I think that's the magic.
I don't even know
how much you guys --
>> Gregor Sigl: No,
I do that too.
I can read.
No, what I find astonishing
is because there's always
that question: is music --
for example, is Beethoven's
music up-to-date?
Is it -- or is it old music?
I think that this is not
even a question to ask
because the more we pick
up that music again, again,
we realize that this is
actually something right there.
It's a an motion.
It's something you can feel.
It doesn't matter when you
feel love or pain or desire.
It's -- it didn't change.
So to realize that this is
such an incredible achievement.
How is it actually possible to
put this on paper with rules,
rules of composing
and just with ink
and paper: how is that possible?
And it's still alive and you
can wake it up at any time
and feel it so deeply.
And that is absolutely
astonishing.
Of course, when you know about
what happened at that time,
it is -- this is fascinating
and opens your eyes.
But at the same time, it is
so -- it's just right there.
The better the composer,
the more obvious it is what
you can read in this core.
It's just with Beethoven
-- in my opinion.
There are not just
not two opinions
about if something
is in a certain way.
It's really fascinating.
So both things are interesting.
You can approach it knowing --
actually, maybe it doesn't work.
I mean, you need to have
a knowledge and you need
to have experience
to understand it.
But once you understand it,
you realize that it's fresh
and it's pure emotion.
>> Vineta Sareika: I actually
like to think of every composer
that we are working and
we play their music.
To think of them like actual
human beings, like my friends,
or like people that I know.
Because I think nowadays
people spend so much time
to build a façade, to appear
a little bit more intelligent
or more beautiful
or more whatever.
And, you know, in this society
is sometimes a bit annoying
that it's impossible to
see the real human being,
you know, behind that.
And I think with music
is a fantastic thing
because it's like a mirror.
It's like there's no
place for this façade.
You can really feel the
person that Mozart was
or that Schumann was or, you
know, it was all their emotions,
was there naiveness
maybe or their shyness
or their great passion
and that's --
>> Anne McLean, Music Division,
Library of Congress:
It's all there.
>> Vineta Sareika:
Yeah, that's great --
a great thinking about music.
>> Anne McLean, Music Division,
Library of Congress: Exactly.
>> Anthea Kreston:
And an amazing part
of being an American having
moved to Berlin and teaching
at the university where we teach
is Clara Schumann taught there
and Robert taught there and
we walk the same walls --
the same halls and you see
the doors where they were.
So many great names of our
-- of what we are doing.
We're right there working as if,
you know, as if they were there,
you know, at the same time.
>> Anne McLean, Music Division,
Library of Congress:
What an inspiration.
>> Anthea Kreston:
Yeah, it's incredible.
It's incredible
>> Anne McLean, Music
Division, Library of Congress:
You really are a
continuity of their lives,
I think, as musicians.
And yet you -- and you
also are doing new music.
I know you work with some
major new music figures
and do very new compositions,
I think,
Jorg Widmann we had
here not so long ago
and other artists
that we admire a lot.
Do you have a new ones coming
up that new compositions
you are going to premier?
>> Gregor Sigl: Yes, we have.
We're doing a project
in the Beethoven year
coming up in 2020.
We asked three composers
that are very close
to us to write something.
And we wanted to avoid doing
the cycle while 25 other --
25,000 other quartets do that.
So we do play Beethoven
and we asked Jorg Widmann,
and Peteris Vasks,
a Latvian composer
and Lera Auerbach
to write for us.
And that will be three programs
that we do in our cycles.
And but we also do -- actually,
I don't know if I'm allowed
to say, but I am going to say
it anyway the American premiere
of the Auerbach piece will
be at Carnegie in 2020.
I'm not sure if it is the
premier or the American premier.
I am not really sure.
But that's something coming up.
>> Anne McLean, Music
Division, Library of Congress:
Those are three great
composers that you've chosen.
I would look to maybe I'll
try to remember this and come
up to do this -- to hear them.
Let's see.
So back to the, sort of,
the more mundane things.
I'm just curious about
how you chose to stand
and only Eckart be seated.
You know, how -- I can see
that this is very freeing.
When did you start doing this?
>> Eckart Runge: We started
doing this about 10 years ago.
And initially it
was a medical issue
because with there
were back problems
of our former first violinist.
And playing the violin is a
very unnatural thing anyway.
But sitting and playing the
violin, is basically suicide
on the long-term side,
you know, for your body
because you never know where
to put the bow and, you know.
So first of all, it was a
first aid measure that we took
to be able to play concerts.
But then it felt good somehow.
It fell free and
it felt natural.
And two violinist
and the viola player
at the time wanted
to stick to it.
So it has the great advantage
that you can first of all --
except for the natural
posture --
it has the advantage that
you can project much more
in bigger halls.
>> Anne McLean, Music
Division, Library of Congress:
Oh, that is interesting.
>> Eckart Runge: We play
in small halls but also
in bigger halls and I think the
string quartets, as you pointed
out the other day, were
not made for big halls.
They were made for
small living rooms.
And there it feels
natural to sit
down because it's
small and intimate.
But if you want to put
this music into a big hall,
it feels more natural
to stand up.
And, of course, there is some
disadvantages also which need
to be considered that a
certain intimacy also which is
in quartet music doesn't get
lost by the gesture of standing
up like a soloist and
projecting and presenting.
You know, and the freedom
to move also needs more
control than sitting down.
Because sitting down, you
cannot move so much, right.
So there are all these
issues that we had
to work a little bit on.
But I think in the end,
it gives a bigger pallet
and so it became also
part of our group somehow.
And we carry around a little
podium which I sit on so
that the playing level of
sitting down altogether is sort
of simulated by the
elevated height.
So we kind of have our heads
and or instruments on one layer
like it is the case
when we all sit down.
So we got used to it
and we kind of enjoy it.
>> Anne McLean, Music Division,
Library of Congress:
That's interesting.
I don't think I have ever
seen a quartet of your type,
not a Baroque quartet, you know,
not a period group play all
standing up except for once.
I think it does make a
wonderful sound actually.
I was just noticing when I
was hearing your rehearsal.
It is a very different
sound for me.
And I want to talk with you to
get your perspective on some
of the pieces on the
program in just a moment.
And I also wanted to ask you
about your life outside
the quartet.
So I know that you have
this duo with the pianist
that you have worked with
for a long time for example.
And I know that three of
you also have children too.
So that's a huge responsibility.
I know [inaudible].
So how do you -- how do you --
what do you do just
for pure fun?
>> Gregor Sigl: If you have
little kids, that is the answer.
You come home and
they don't care at all
if you just returned
from Carnegie.
They just -- you are
confronted very basic stuff
and so refreshing and it's just
the very best way to recharge is
to just go home and
be with a kid.
It's totally -- it's
the best thing to do.
>> Anthea Kreston:
I have recently become
really interested in writing
and I have a blog that I write.
And I just online book club.
And so -- and the online
book club is really exciting.
Eugene Drucker from the Emerson
Quartet is my first guest
and he speaking about his book.
And I don't really know how
to write, but it's really fun.
And it has become an
obsession for me and kind
of a new part of my life.
>> Anne McLean, Music
Division, Library of Congress:
I have read just a few
of your blog entries
which were very interesting.
And I want to go
back and read more.
Are they all on Slipped Disc?
If you're not familiar
with this website,
I think you would really
like it: slippedisc.com.
It's a long-standing, very
interesting musical site.
Originally I guess
it's Norman Lebrecht --
but anyway, I saw the blog that
you did about the Curtis Sound.
Which interested
me and I wondered
if you would maybe talk
just a little bit about that
because having perspective on
this -- what this sound is,
I've never seen it in writing.
I've never heard
it talked about.
But what made me note
this when I saw your blog,
was we just had the
Dover Quartet here.
And as soon as they began
to play, I said, wow,
they've all been to Curtis.
And I hadn't really
thought about that.
There're other people
too as soon
as you walk in, you hear it.
There was a young man a
young bassist Xavier Foley,
I heard him at the Kennedy
Center two weeks ago and I said,
oh, he's been to Curtis.
But what is its sound?
>> Anthea Kreston: Well, I
think it's this extremely --
well, Curtis is a warehouse
of all musical musicians
-- music and musicians.
It's kind of like, come here
and tell us everything you've
learned and all the people
that you -- and it takes
care of the older musicians
and it brings them in
and it just nurtures them
and then they nurture --
of course, they have these
fantastic young students.
So that is one thing.
It is just a warehouse
and a museum --
a living museum of sound.
And the same time, it's so
small, it's only the size
of a single orchestra.
So there is only one tuba
opening every four years,
for example.
And the orchestral
training for so many years
with Otto-Werner Mueller,
it was so vigorous and so --
and some people say
that there was no human
that had a more depth
of knowledge
of Western classical
music then Mueller.
And he just trained us and then,
of course, about 20 percent
of the principal players and all
the top 10 American orchestras
are Curtis trained so that goes
throughout and the conductors,
and so it's like this web.
And there is only one way
to play a quarter note.
There isn't -- there's not a
negotiable quarter note length.
There is one way and if
you are in an orchestra,
that's how it's going to be and
how all the teachers believe.
And then, you know,
perhaps later
on in your life you might
dabble with the idea
that there is a different
quarter note possibility.
But, you know, probably not.
So that's why you
hear the Dover Quartet
and I would know exactly how
long their quarter notes are.
And if you sit down with
someone who went to Curtis,
you are going to know how
long the quarter note is.
>> Anne McLean, Music Division,
Library of Congress: Now see,
that's one of the one things I
didn't quite understand was a
quarter note is what it is.
I mean, how -- do
some people top it off
or they don't give it
its full value or...?
>> Anethea Kreston: That
is a very deep question.
>> Gregor Sigl: Well, that
will take a while, yeah.
>> Anthea Kreston: Yeah, yeah.
That's a really long -- that's
a heavy, heavy question.
But it's -- that's
basically in a nutshell.
But it's such a small
concentrated, like,
bouillon of knowledge.
It's -- and it's so
strict and it's so close
and everyone knows everything.
And there's no way to
-- and it's so true.
It's so true, so you
can't disagree with it --
anyway, if you disagree,
you are out!
You're out the next day!
>> Anne McLean, Music Division,
Library of Congress:
Oh, my goodness.
>> Anthea Kreston:
No, I am just joking.
But, not really.
A little bit.
>> Anne McLean, Music Division,
Library of Congress: Well,
it's fascinating -- well, you
know, obviously, we could --
it sounds like we
need more time.
But maybe we could move
slightly sideways from that
and just say quickly: is there
a German quartet sound anymore?
Maybe not?
>> Gregor Sigl: I
don't think so.
No, I don't think so.
>> Eckart Runge: I think
quartets changed with time.
And they reflect the
time they lived in.
Fifty years ago I think quartets
were very connected to a region
or a city like, you know,
the Gewandhaus Quartet would
be four people from Leipzig.
They wouldn't accept
anyone who was not Saxonian
in that quartet, you know.
They still don't.
But then you had, you know,
the original Tokyo Quartet,
of course, they were
all from Tokyo.
And the Alban Berg Quartet, they
were all Viennese or Austrian.
And this changed a lot.
So I think -- as the
world gets more globalized
and more speeding up and
everything is more open
and short term somehow,
changes in quartets
and the international aspect
of quartets has also become more
visible in the quartet world.
And I think we are a pretty
good example, for this we --
now we have three
nationalities in the quartet.
And, for example,
the Barchet Quartet
at some point they had four
people from different countries.
And I think that's
-- they still have?
I know two of them
are Swiss, no?
No, French?
Well anyway, Swiss-French,
it's kind of the same.
Anyway, but, yeah, but I
think it reflects our time
and I don't know if there
is a German quartet sound.
I am sure we don't have it.
>> Anne McLean, Music
Division, Library of Congress:
That's interesting for me
just because, you know,
I've had so many years of
listening to great quartets.
It's been a privilege and so
when I first began working here,
I did encounter German
quartets and French quartets
and even Italian quartets and
there was, in my experience,
a much more perceptible
unified national type of sound.
And now this is my perception
now: it's not so much.
As you say, people have
grown into new worlds.
>> Eckart Runge:
We are from Berlin.
And I think also this
is an important parts
of the city's atmosphere
and feel
and vision and image of today.
It's very international.
It's very open.
It has changed a lot
in the last 28 years.
And I think that's why we also
enjoy being there and identify
with where we come from.
I remember then when we were
studying, we went to Vienna
to study with Alban
Berg Quartet.
And as every quartet needs to
take a decision at some point:
where are we going to live?
Basically, you could
live anywhere
because you earn your money
not where you live basically.
And so you can choose a place
from where you start your tours.
And it does make sense to choose
a place which you identify with.
And we went to Vienna,
it was so clear
that we were not a
Viennese quartet,
that Vienna would be
an intermediate time
and we loved it.
It was great.
And it was a fantastic
inspiration, a very important
for us -- also the
strong connection
to the Alban Berg Quartet and
the whole tradition of them.
But it was totally clear
that we would not stay there
because we are not
a Viennese quartet.
I think you are sort of an
ambassador of the city you come
from more than the
country you come from.
>> Gregor Sigl: And just
to add to this question
of German quartet sound,
I think the only thing
that I can feel strongly
is I think it is --
you can hear if a person --
a person's mother language
is connected to music.
I feel that especially in Brahms
and Shuman also in Schumann also
in Shubert those composers
that draw out a lot of lead
and work very intimately
with text
and with the German language.
And so that feels -- for me
that feels so much at home.
I feel such a strong
relation maybe
because my mother sang a Brahms
song for me when I was little,
or I grew up with
the folk music there.
And I can feel, for example,
with Viennese musicians,
I can feel that maybe perhaps
they have this Viennese charm
just a touch more than others.
Yeah, you can feel that.
But, of course, nowadays,
people learn from each other
because you travel so quickly
and you study wherever you like.
Perhaps the most extreme
for me is the Hungarian
language because, of course,
Bartok is such an important part
of the string quartet
literature.
And for me it's his music
is like a foreign language.
I can realize how great it
is and I love to work on it,
but it always remains a
very foreign language.
And I can hear when --
when I hear native Hungarian
people play their music,
and I hear the very strong
connection to the internation
and to the rhythm and the
phrasing of that language.
And it will always
remain foreign.
Maybe I can do that well,
but I cannot feel it
like a mother language.
>> Anne McLean, Music Division,
Library of Congress: Yeah.
I know what you mean.
I have in my mind's ear
the Bartok Quartet playing
who studied with Bartok and the
Yvonne Fisher [assumed spelling]
brought members of the
Budapest Festival Orchestra here
to play a chamber evening
with a variety of music,
some piano solo, some
-- the contrast for,
you know, with the clarinet.
And it was so different.
Their interpretations
were so different
than any I had ever heard.
But this is a good movement,
quickly, into asking you
about the Schumann Quartet
because it has those elements
of the Hungarian style
Steal Anqua [phonetic].
And can you may maybe tell
a little to the audience
about what they'll
hear in this piece --
the Hungarian style elements.
>> Gregor Sigl: But you can hear
that a German guy tried to --
it was some kind
of very fashionable
and very interesting
at that time.
But for me -- I know, I think
I know what you pointing at.
I could still hear the -- I can
still hear that he was German.
I think.
>> Eckart Runge: Saxonian.
>> Gregor Sigl: Saxonian.
>> Anne McLean, Music Division,
Library of Congress: So, yeah.
You'll hear these
various elements
like a little drone elements
and certain rhythmic patterns
and pizzicato, so
forth and so on.
Well, maybe one more
question for you
and then other people may have a
couple questions before you go.
In the Shostakovich
Quartet there is --
the three movements are
played attacca right there --
right together then you
can even hear this work
as almost one movement
if you think like that.
But I wanted to ask you to come
in on the dramatic
bar of silence.
That is, before the third
movement and how that --
how you feel about that.
What does it say to you?
It is a notated bar, right or...
>> Gregor Sigl: It is -- I
don't think he was aiming
for cutting it apart.
I think it is -- I mean
often the most tension is
during breaks.
So I think the important
thing for us --
what we are trying
to do is also to --
the unknown factor and the
question what's coming,
that's the strong thing and
it should not at all stop.
A break is not necessarily
a stop.
>> Anthea Kreston:
What happens right
after it, is total crazy chaos.
I mean, I need that bar to just
realize what is about to happen.
>> Vineta Sareika: It
is a shock every time.
>> Anthea Kreston: Yeah.
>> Vineta Sareika: For all of us
>> Anthea Kreston: Yeah,
yeah it's like bugh!
[phonetic].
Yeah, you need that.
>> Eckart Runge: The bar is
a huge buildup of tension.
>> Anthea Kreston: Yes, yeah.
>> Eckart Runge:
Like if someone --
>> Anthea Kreston: Gathered.
>> Eckart Runge: --
talks in a, let's say,
tense or even threatening way
and becomes softer and softer
and then he stops to talk,
that's the really scary moment.
So, and I think this is a little
bit what happens in that music.
>> Anne McLean, Music
Division, Library of Congress:
I want to make sure that you had
a chance to hear what they had
to say about that
because it is a kind
of an important moment there.
Well, this -- we hate to stop.
I mean, there's so many more
things we could talk about.
And you guys are
great in this way.
But does anyone have
a couple of questions
to ask before they have to
go and warm up and so on.
Any particular things?
No. Maybe one.
>> Unknown Speaker 1: You have
mentioned the experience working
with quartets from different
countries with master classes
and the -- it amplifies
your experience
of the possibilities of quartet.
I wonder if you listen
to recordings,
and what is your
response to them?
Does that add a dimension that's
important for you to understand
or is there something
more alienating
that doesn't give you
the same experience?
>> Vineta Sareika: Well, I think
we are all four very different
with it also.
It's like with reading
and that background thing.
I think for me personally, I, of
course, I listen to recordings
in the beginning
to know the piece.
So I listen to a couple of them.
Not to influence
myself too much.
So I pick maybe three or
four different versions.
But then during the time when
we build up our own version,
I try not to listen at all.
I listen to other pieces of
that composer, you know, but --
because I think it's very --
you don't realize the moment
when you get influenced
by something,
that it's great maybe, a
version that's totally my taste.
But I just want to make
sure that it's our version
and it is not --
that we stay honest
with what we feel
the composer wanted
and not some other
great artists felt.
So but, of course, it's always
interesting to also listen
to other people and
to keep surprised
by the other options
that they find.
>> Gregor Sigl: Also listening
to other people's performances
not only inspires you
to do the same.
It might also make you think
why I want to do it differently,
or why is it the version
sounds so differently?
And I think it's important
to listen a lot and to go
to concerts a lot because,
yeah, or even negative things,
something you don't like
can influence you a lot
and make you learn.
And also, I don't think
there is a danger that --
in our case, I think
I can say --
the danger of copying
something is not there
because no matter how much you
listen or how much you learn
from someone, you always have
your own voice and as soon
as you play it and perform it,
it will sound different anyway.
And it's the same like with
the greatness of that music,
what I said about
Beethoven, that it's so pure.
And it's the same when you are
an honest musician that tries
to make honest music and just
project your own emotions,
it will sound like you.
It will not sound
like someone else.
So I think -- I don't
think there's a danger
and I think it's very healthy
and very inspiring
to listen a lot.
And, of course, you know for
us as string quartet players,
it's so -- I think I can speak
for all of us, when you listen
to a different quartet, a
good quartet, it's so much joy
because we -- I can't
listen to my own recordings.
It's -- I only hear mistakes
that I remember the moment
we did it and why we did it
and when we rehearsed and
when we had a fight about it.
It's very hard.
And when you listen to another
good group, you can let go
and you can see that music
in a different light.
And it's very -- it's so great.
I love it.
>> Anne McLean, Music Division,
Library of Congress: Any other?
Did you have a question?
Yeah.
>> Unknown Speaker 2: Thank you.
[inaudible] and musicians but
Ms. Kreston, you mentioned
about your activities.
You have a full engaged and
demanding global tour schedule,
but you also teach
in University.
But you mentioned
briefly about [inaudible]
in Waterloo, in Brussels.
So do you mentor
young musicians?
>> Anthea Kreston:
Yes, absolutely.
So the question is: do we
mentor young musicians?
And a little bit about that.
Is that correct?
So, of course, being a classical
musician you are kind of always
at a different layer
of the tiramisu.
So sometimes you're at the
bottom, sometimes you're
in the middle, sometimes
you're in the top; but is all,
you know, that rum or whatever
is on the bottom is so good,
it's going to work its way up.
And so, not only do
we learn by teaching,
but I'm in so inspired
by those students.
And then when I get
that score --
Oh, they're going to be
working on this piece.
And then I dig out my old
score and I see my old --
And then I scan it and I send
it to them and I'm like, Oh,
these are Isaac Stern's
fingerings.
You're going to love these.
And I send them early.
And so I really learn
and I reconnect with,
how long is a quarter note?
No, I am joking.
But it reteaches us and it
re-invigorates our own passion
and then also not only
that, we are so lucky.
You should hear these
students we get to teach.
They are unbelievable!
They are so, I'm like, I
want to be in that quartet.
You know, they are
just so fantastic.
Like recent -- people
who have graduated
from our class Arod
string quartet --
I don't know if you've
had them yet.
Unbelievable!
These guys are crazy.
All of these groups that
we play with, they are --
they feed our passion
and their desire
for knowledge is insatiable.
And so all that -- you realize
what's wrong with yourself
and what you -- you realize
again what you do know.
And then they ask --
they are very aggressive.
They ask questions and
you have to answer.
You know, you can't just be
like, well, I just think this.
I mean, they'll reall...
>> Eckart Runge: May I
add something to this?
I think that, sorry --
>> Vineta Sareika: I think
what is interesting also
that those groups already
have such a high level
that it is not only about music.
We speak about music a lot,
but it's also about how to deal
with the musician's life and
with concert life, with stress,
with touring, with
being in harmony
with the other members
of their groups.
If they have some
communication problems,
we try to solve them together
and it's really interesting
on the human level as well.
>> Eckart Runge: I remember from
myself being a young musician,
I was so fortunate
to have teachers
that were the right people
in the right moment
not only teaching me
about quarter note lengths.
Also about aspects about, you
know, that develop personality.
Because I think that's
the most hard thing
about an artistic studies is
that you cannot read a book,
learn it, know it, go to
the exam, get a great grade,
go out of school,
get a great job.
That doesn't work.
There are so many other
aspects of the building
of a personality, of
character, of self-confidence,
of sensitivity; of
course, they all have
to already somehow
be there in a talent.
And also the passion, the
drive, and the energy to work
and the discipline, there is
so many ingredients especially
in a group you have it times
four, right, or times three
in a trio, I mean, yeah.
That all this fits together
is way beyond only teaching
and interpretation of a piece.
And so I, again, say clearly,
yes, to your question.
I think it is very, very
important to mentor groups,
young groups, the way we
were lucky to have enjoyed
that by wonderful teachers.
And now, we are trying to
pass on a little bit of this
from our own experience.
We know how hard and
stony this road can be.
And one of the biggest dangers,
especially of very
successful young groups,
are that they get
destroyed by their success.
And it's so tempting to
accept all these offers
and play all these concerts.
And it's so hard for a young
group to turn down offers
and say, no, we need
the time to develop.
And this is, for me personally,
always a great challenge
to consider with these groups,
to maintain the sustainability
of a group.
Because young people tend to
lose that out of their sight
and we were lucky enough to
kind of survive until today.
But it was also, we had our
really hard moments, you know.
And I know that this life looks
always so shiny when you walk
on stage and you perform
and everyone thinks,
they just do it.
It's very easy.
But it's not.
And it takes years and
years and a lot of aspects
around music to make that work.
>> Anne McLean, Music
Division, Library of Congress:
It's inspirational to
hear talk about this
and it reflects in your music.
I know -- yeah, please.
>> Gregor Sigl: I
just want to add.
It's a very, very
strong responsibility.
And we don't always succeed.
I mean, we had groups or we
have at the moment people
in their early 20s are
having a very serious burn
out because recording company
contract and 100 concerts
and too much repertoire.
And on some levels they
were not ready for it.
Maybe they can do everything.
They can play everything
and they wow the audience.
But something was too much.
And that's something
we try to tell them,
that music is a lifelong
process anyway.
Take your time with it,
but not everyone listens.
And that's an important thing
to try to slow down a bit.
>> Anne McLean, Music Division,
Library of Congress: Well,
thank you for talking so
candidly and beautifully
about everything with us.
We really appreciate
this opportunity.
And we need to get
them backs stage.
So thanks, and...
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.